We end this lecture sequence
with the most important
property of expectations,
namely linearity.
The idea is pretty simple.
Suppose that our random
variable, X, is the salary of
a random person out of
some population.
So that we can think of the
expected value of X as the
average salary within
that population.
And now suppose that everyone
gets a raise, and
Y is the new salary.
And generously, the new salary
is twice the old salary plus a
bonus of $100.
What happens to the expected
value of the salary, or the
average salary?
Well the new average salary,
which is the expected value of
2X plus 100, is twice the
old average plus 100.
So doubling everyone's salary
and giving to everyone an
additional $100, what it does
to the average is that it
doubles the average and
adds 100 to it.
This is the linearity property
of expectation in one
particular example.
It's a most intuitive property,
but it's worth also
deriving it in a formal way.
And the derivation proceeds
through the
expected value rule.
We're dealing here with a
particular function, g, which
is a linear function.
So we're dealing with a linear
function, ax plus b.
And we're dealing with a random
variable, Y, which is g
applied to an original
random variable, X.
So the expected value of Y can
be calculated according to the
expected value rule.
It's the sum over all x's of g
of x times the probability of
that particular x.
And we plug-in the specific form
of the function, g, which
is ax plus b.
And then we separate the
sum into two sums.
The first sum, after pulling
out a constant of
a, takes this form.
And the second sum, after
pulling out the constant, b,
takes this form.
Now, the first sum is a times
the expected value of X. This
is just the definition of
the expected value.
As, for the second sum, we
realize that this quantity is
equal to 1 because it is the
sum of the probabilities of
all the different values of X.
And this concludes the proof
of the linearity of
expected values.
Notice that for expected values,
what we have is that
the expected value of Y, which
is expected value of g of X,
is this same as g of the
expected value of X. The
expected value of a linear
function is the same linear
function applied to the
expected value.
But this is an exceptional
case.
This does not happen
in general.
It's an exceptional function
g that makes this happen.
This property is true for
linear functions.
But for non-linear functions,
it is generally false.